et bélie qu'est ce qui te ramène je
gagnais voit d'où je viens je vous
souhaite un bon séjour
mais gardez l'oeil ouvert on a eu des
petits problèmes à la barre soyez
prudent nous sert apparaît à ceux qui se
lèvent tous je t'en prie pas parlé
depuis ce matin on n'a pas vu un seul
animal papa
[Musique]
daniel dépêche oh mon dieu qu'est ce qui
s'est passé lors un faux-cul lui sauve
la vie a perdu une tonne au sens voilà
chez mon fils tout de suite je peux pas
faire ça j'ai besoin de cet argent
le m'expliquer ce qui s'est passé mon
fils est dans cette voiture je
trouverais cauris et les bars et son
livre à almaty de récupérer l'argent
pour lui ça tourne pas rond histoire
ce turnover il faut rien dire à la
police croit qu'il est nommé cheval et
quoiqu'il en
lâche ça fait quelque chose qui dit
mieux
l'un si ce n'est pour que je parle pas
la police qu'est-ce que j'étais censé
parer à cet argent est ma seule chance
de retrouver son fils alors dépôt des
recours et office
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucune chasse nouveau la chasse à
l'homme